this might be the coolest visualization
of climate change I've ever seen what
you're looking at is cumulative changes
in carbon dioxide in the atmosphere over
a year in 3D going up to about 10
kilometers in altitude there's so much
to unpack here the swirling butterscotch
is anthropogenic emissions of carbon
dioxide from burning fossil fuels look
at how the Northern Hemisphere dominates
carbon emissions early on we can see
individual countries that are large
emitters such as China fast forward
through the year though and we can see
how well mixed that Northern Hemisphere
carbon is and just how much of it there
is the other colors are just as
interesting though blue is ocean uptaker
carbon and green is biological land
uptake such as by the Amazon rainforest
you can see how the rainforest breeds
carbon in during the day when it's
photosynthesizing the sun total of these
factors varies over the year initially
fossil fuels produce a rise in global
CO2 levels but as the Northern
Hemisphere moves into summer lots of
carbon is sunk into biomass by the end
of the year and Northern Hemisphere
Winter though fossil fuel emissions
outweigh biological uptake and the
atmosphere has more CO2 in it because of
human emissions than at the start of the
year as it has every year for decades